l'événement était bien sûr ici vous le
savez merci encore d'ailleurs d'être
aussi nombreux à regarder touche pas à
mon poste encore une semaine de j'ai
voulu venir pour être très honnête alors
déjà première chose je vais vraiment
être transparents sur le moment je les
ai pas du tout vécu comme une agression
sexuelle parce que c'est le terme que
j'entends et qui est employé sur les
réseaux sociaux
alors c'est la définition c'est la
définition d'une agression sexuelle moi
je n'ai pas du tout vécu comme ça mais
je les ai vécu comme une humiliation
parce qu'après il faut être honnête il
faut aussi dire les choses parfois dans
ce métier là en tant que journaliste
sportive on se retrouve à être humilié
parce que y'a voilà il ya des mots qui
sont blessants il ya des comportements
et le fait qu'on soit une femme
voilà autorise certains a manqué de
respect on s'était embrouillé toi et moi
il ya 4 ou 5 ans parce que tu avais
souleymane diouf devant tout le monde tu
te souviens tu te souviens pas du tout
tu te souviens pas
et pas du tout tu vois moi je m'en
souviens ouais parce que tu leur ferait
aujourd'hui oui soulever la jupe de
quelqu'un comme ça même en sachant que
ça peut être humiliant c'est à humilier
oui je suis désolé
ouais mais il faut aussi prendre les
gens comme ils sont beaux costumes aussi
prendre des gens comme messieurs
francesca on a on est beaucoup sortis
ensemble j'ai toujours accepté
j'aimais bien ces petites et chambrage
c'est vrai que là tu vois tu parles de
ta famille et j'imagine à quel point
cela doit être compliqué t'imagines
quand tu vois cette image soit moi mon
fils aussi pareil c'est compliqué là il
revoit cette image sur les réseaux
sociaux dit maman je me rappelais plus
bien de ce truc explique - mais comment
ça se fait pour accepter ça et donc
c'est aussi des trucs comme moi ma mère
pareil donc nous aussi on en fait c'est
juste ça maintenant il faut qu'on se
dise que voilà faut faire attention pour
ne rien faire
non mais c'est à dire que moi moi je
pour tout ce qui s'est passé l'âge et
des profonds regrets vraiment et
sincèrement que ce soit profonde c'est
ce que j'aime depuis très longtemps
isabelle marie m'enfin bon mari j'ai
quand même accepté d'y aller faire son
truc
si ça n'a pas été diffusée c'est pas de
mon ressort c'est un choix et avec son
11e a diffusé à non j'ai rien demandé
est-ce que tu comprends que ça fasse
polémique ou pas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui oui à l'époque ça n'a pas
fait polémique à l'époque quand
j'embrasse isabelle moreau pour la
centième du cfc tout le plateau est
hilare tout le public applaudit dans
cette scène là c'est pareil aujourd'hui
ça fera un scandale affreux tancrez
alors je vous dire qu'on voulait
dialoguer des délinquantes comptabilisé
mortier suis je m'en voulais vous
dialoguez avec des trafiquants je
rejoins légère expliquer comment vous
voulez dialoguer ça n'est jamais autant
les policiers que les jeunes de carélie
au contraire ils ont qu une envie je
vous le dis c'est diallo villes
chinoises etc est un chanteur ben oui
jeunes des quartiers peu moi j'ai
toujours très bien dialoguer avec les
gens des quartiers populaires vous savez
je dialogue avec eux car j'étais
policier c'est un effort j'arrive à
avoir de très bons rapports avec eux
mais à côté de ça avec les choufs et
avec les vendeurs mais forcément j'avais
un dialogue et qui était moins évident
lui ce que dit patrick poivre d'arvor
suite à tous cette malheureuse affaire
il dit les écrits de madame porcel que
j'ai conservé pour la plupart
postérieure à ces accusations le
prouveront amplement parce qu'il a gardé
tous les mails a coûté une histoire qui
va vous intéresser qui folle et
géraldine à vous intéresser
particulièrement parce que vous êtes fan
c'est une histoire qui concerne novak
djokovic le numéro un mondial du net
servian de tomber regardez cette
histoire une interview explosive de
natalia ce qui est kitsch une mannequin
serbe a été publié dans un magazine
la jeune femme révèle avoir été
sollicité pour participer à une
opération martic particulièrement
malveillantes dont la cible était novak
djokovic elle dit un homme que je
connais si et que je croyait jusque-là
sérieux m'a contacté pour un rendez vous
que je pensais professionnel au fil de
notre conversation j'ai vite compris que
quelque chose n'allait pas je pensais
même à une caméra cachée quand il m'a
expliqué que je devais séduire novak
djokovic il m'a dit que je pouvais je
pouvais obtenir 60 mille euros pour cela
est un voyage où je voulais j'ai rigolé
je pensais qu'il allait me dire qu'il
blaguait mais cet homme était très
sérieux rapidement l'objectif immoral
lui a été présentée elle devait tout
faire pour charmer novak djokovic dans
le but d'enregistrer une vidéo de leurs
rapports sexuels à son insu la sextape
aurait ensuite été dévoilée au monde
entier pour faire scandale et porté
atteinte à sa réputation va devoir à sa
carrière après moi ce qui m'a choqué
dans l'attitude de pierre ménès que je
connais beaucoup moins que plusieurs
d'entre vous c'est la manière dont en
fait il était centré sur lui c'est à
dire qu'il est vraiment venu en disant
qu'il avait passé une mauvaise journée
sans aucune pensée pour toutes les
femmes qui avait été traumatisée par
cette attitude quand même son attitude a
fait l'objet de plusieurs témoignages de
témoignages ou multiple le fait qu' il
explique que finalement ce qui est
regrette c'est qu'on ait changé d'époque
et que mis tout ça correspond à 1 on ne
peut plus rien dire
non me tout c'est la peau c'est la
possibilité pour des femmes de
s'exprimer à leur calibre des ddd des
violences sexuelles et des violences
sexuelles et sexistes donc le fait de
réduire mis tout à sa personne au fait
que ça l' entrave dans la possibilité
qu'il avait malheureusement de de
perpétrer des agressions parce que moi
ce que j'ai vu ce sont des agressions
sexuelles
qui est fou c'est un journaliste possède
moi qui a subi une incroyable injustice
sur une simple ressemblance avec une
image vidéo
il a été soupçonné d'être un des trois
terroristes de l'attentât du 22 mars
2016 à bruxelles il a été arrêté inculpé
ce n'est qu'en janvier dernier qu'il a
été enfin mis définitivement hors de
cause et qu'il a obtenu des excuses de
la justice c'est une histoire incroyable
on monte dans la voiture on prend la
route inédite qui est qui prend sa soeur
également pour l'emmener à faire des
cours du soir
et là on est pris en filature par la
police et là d'un coup une voiture
banalisée débarquent par la gauche
une autre en cercle et là je vois des
des flics
à ce moment il n'y a pas que des
policiers mais des hommes armés et des
vêtements couleur kaki qu ça me faisait
penser à des militaires pas des
militaires et là je n'ai pas le temps de
réaliser ça va mais ça va très vite en
fête est donc pas le temps de voir les
brassards et c'est moi je me suis
content j'ai vu une chose c'est un
policier en face de moi avec une
mitraillette et donc vraiment un fusil
d'assaut
kim figé et qui me qui tremblaient on
appelait pour moi le ministre de
l'intérieur le premier ministre et le
ministre la justice et demande qui me
garde
elle me dit moi je suis pour les droits
de la défense je vais aller sur place
ces cow-boys de policiers moi je travail
sérieux c'est le juge d'instruction
je vais aller sur place et je vais
reprendre cette affaire parce que ça
devient louche et surtout quand il lui a
dit il m'a dit pourquoi vous avez refusé
le tapissage qu'est ce que c'est le
tapissage un certain jean bart rappelait
tapissage c'est quand vous avez
plusieurs personnes qui sont alignés et
il ya une des personnes bien entendu qui
peut être reconnu comme étant le symbole
on m'avait parlé de ça d'accord je dis
mais qu'est ce que c'est que jamais on
va parler de ça tapait à la halle dans
la cellule et où ils ont vu une lumière
flash je dormais pas et c'était
impossible de dormir donc je veux ça
c'est je regarde la télévision j'entends
mais alors tout un truc des des
spécialistes experts qui viennent de
paraître paralysant des plateaux pendant
20 minutes en disant par exemple mais le
patron de paris match le pour parle de
paris match qui dit mais c'est un homme
avec un sang-froid une détermination et
célina et j'ai en fait je me posais
public donc je suis là j'écoute ces
derniers placements voilà je vais passer
le restant de ma vie on sait maintenant
je commence à me trouver
le coupable est entendu là vous étiez
soulageront oui jours plus tard huit
jours plus tard donc pendant huit jours
gullit sa maman retrouver de sable
pendant huit jours c'est moi oui j'ai eu
tort je reconnais j'ai eu tort de les
traiter de cons vous avez dit quoique
fait chier vous êtes des cons et rien
d'autre à [ __ ]
voilà vous nommez texas et pas une autre
ça s'appelle on découvre que la palapa
ouvert depuis des mois et des mois
c'est normal qu'elle a craqué le dire au
moment où ils vous ont interpellé
évidemment c'est partir en cacahuète
ça c'est le trop classique vous les avez
outragés évidemment un rebellyon c'est
le procès ce jour moi je voulais pas le
jeter l'opprobre sur mes collègues
policiers parce que ils sont dans une
situation actuelle tout le monde le sait
avec ce qu'on vide qui est compliquée et
je comprends que votre situation en tant
que commerçante est très compliqué mais
en même temps si vous aviez su vous
contenir un petit peu mais je sais que
c'est pas simple j'entends je pense que
ça ne se serait pas passé comme ça avec
le but c'était de les piéger d'avoir
leurs réactions
mais le but premier c'était d'avoir les
réactions de monsieur bourdin on y va et
et là forcément dons qu'ils arrivent
dans la voiture et l'idée c'était voilà
vous êtes monsieur bourdin et là tout de
suite elle me dit et pas que je me dis
oui je sais vous êtes sa femme non
journaliste reporter de guerre et si mon
mari on est là aujourd'hui c'est en
grande partie grâce à moi ok pose le
décor très bien et dont l'audition dans
le ils sont dans le truc
qu'est ce qu'ils lisent dans la voiture
on veut savoir où on s'en fou maintenant
tabarka c'est un magazine de ce que je
me rappelle c'était que vous était un
très mauvais interviewer un bon cru le
coeur de métier
bourreau avec vos chroniqueurs non mais
que c'était une émission de marc lafosse
papa haut de gamme quoi c'est ce que je
me rappelle des souvenirs et de la
matinale qui jamais plus de force
mes jambes n'étaient que des bleus je
pouvais plus touché le bras larges baies
et e
et puis après il m'a dit tu sais on n'a
pas d'argent foot avec travailler tu as
les marchés à la madeleine et moi je dis
mais qu'est ce que je vais qu'est ce que
je vais marcher à la madeleine il m'a
dit ya des hommes qui vont aborder parce
qu'il m'avait vendu
il m'a vendu un allemand des caves et
nous très riche d'ailleurs et et donc il
m'avait vendu 100 millions et il a été
porté plainte et ils ont été arrêtés lui
son cousin la fermeture des classes et
le confinement vers lequel de toute
façon ne manquera pas d'aller mais un
vrai cette fois ci c'est uniquement dû à
l'impérissable un gouvernement qui n'a
rien prévu et n'a rien fait
contrairement aux autres pays comme la
grande bretagne les états unis même même
des pays comme les émirats ou comme le
chili font mieux que nous donc moi
aujourd'hui la république en marche
franchement je me ferais très très
discret alors j'ai des démissionnaires
vous péter la gueule oui et mode
moi je pense que fermer les écoles ça
doit être une usine une mesure vraiment
de dernière où ils vont le faire ou pas
vous êtes on est ce sera vraiment du
dernier recours et aujourd'hui ça ne
s'est pas de nom aujourd'hui c'est pas
d'actualité on est dans des pays au
monde qui a maintenu le plus les écoles
ouvertes
et si en fait c'est une fierté c'est une
fierté parce que maintenir les écoles
ouvertes c'est une mesure de justice
sociale